kind of like that movie what's that
steve's on movie you know
look candy cane what's the
joyride it's like joyride i mean it's
not like joyride but
you know what i mean just in terms of be
careful
so unhinged is a movie where russell
crowe plays a guy who's pretty unhinged
in terms of movies living up to its
title this is probably
it's up there so the premise is there's
this lady she's a single mom she lives
with her brother
one day she's having a really bad day
and then there's this guy
in his truck and he's not moving when
the light's green so she just
she honks at him i don't mean like honks
at him she goes full i want to speak to
your manager now just bruh
she lets that horn have it so russell
crowe's like i think i'm gonna
stalk the [ __ ] out of this lady and
terrorize her and kill people
we'll make a day of it and that's what
it is there's this horror movie in which
russell crowe is just a really
terrifying maniac and he's terrorizing
this lady which i i would call it horror
i mean it's definitely
thriller but in a world where halloween
is horror then this is horror i mean
halloween is about a guy who stalks a
girl and kills people and
unhinges about a guy who stalks a lady
and kills people so
if one is horror both have to be yeah
sure it's all about execution but i'm
just saying
russell crowe is pretty terrifying i
don't say that lightly when maximum
meridius over here is just
he's doing his thing you're like look
see this is why
people avoid altercations really it's
not just the possibility that when you
get into an altercation it might be a
fight if there's a fight you might get
knocked out if you get knocked out it
ends there
that's not the bad premise so you know
that's not worst case scenario
worst case scenario is you had an
altercation with someone who's just
that bored has that much time on their
hands and they're just gonna [ __ ] with
you now and
you know put your bunny in a pot or to
burn your house but russell crowe is
really good when he's
being that guy and he's doing his really
intense
psycho thing like there's a scene in
this diner i was like this is
intense and uncomfortable and in that i
enjoyed this movie it gave me some
thrills it's simple to the point pretty
intense and intense
it's intense among its chase sequences
involving a minivan and a station wagon
just saying to make it work and there's
something about this premise like this
general premise of this movie of like
oh just careful who you piss off or
careful who you
get into the crosshairs of that i've
always just kind of found
fascinating because it does when you're
watching it you have that feeling of who
could happen to you
you know that movie it could happen to
you this should actually be called it
could happen to you
i'm just saying it's more likely that
someone's gonna [ __ ]
psycho out on you than you winning a lot
of tickets so it's
more applicable for this movie the title
that is
all right i'm editing this video right
now and i just found the poster so i
just saw
that the catch phrase is he could happen
to anyone
which is pretty intense it's more
intense than it could happen to you
but you know they thought of it could
happen to you don't have
there's your update back to your
regularly scheduled program
you do have to take some leaps or at
least suspend disbelief it's like this
lady
in this movie was she was making all the
wrong decisions
until until she wasn't i was always like
lady why aren't you doing this thing and
then she was like oh now i'm gonna do
that thing
but it was always after i thought it and
so it was
one step behind like she should have
done that one step
ago i mean they write their way around
it you know they're like all right we
have to make things happen so she gets
distracted you know writing like
writing in movies like this goes but
there was one scene in particular
russell crowe is just
prattling on the phone and she's driving
i'm like where are you driving to
though are you just driving in circles
are you circling the block cause i feel
like you should have been like uh-huh
oh god that's really terrifying yep i'm
pulling into the police station right
now thanks
you have my phone awesome we'll find you
and really the whole thing gets set off
with bad decision making because
when she realizes hey this truck wait a
minute is that guy following me
this lady's like you want me to call the
cops this one dipshit's like
don't do that that'll just make him mad
and she's like
i'm gonna follow your advice i guess
yeah who wants an official police report
in case this guy really loses it who
wants
a paper trail you don't want that that's
just you know smart
in the end the movie was simple it was a
simple premise
it had its thrills it had its scares
and i was entertained i mean yeah
granted half the reason i was
entertained was probably because i was
like whoa
i'm in a movie theater i almost forgot
what this was like
so yeah that probably added to my
enjoyment sure is this the kind of movie
now that is playing in a movie theater
not near you is this the kind of movie
you need to drive a hundred miles to
watch this weekend
no but for what it was as i watched it i
enjoyed it it's like the kind of movie
that if it's on
tv i'll keep it on i'll be like oh yeah
that movie all right cool
let's see russell crowe just [ __ ]
lose it i'm just saying i had a good
time with this movie no alcohol required
all right so unhinged not a lot of
theater showing it and the auditorium
today wasn't that packed so
do you want to watch it what are you
watching this weekend
what on netflix are you gonna watch what
is it what do you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you